you mentioned uh the democratic uh uh do
you see the democratic party
or the american government whatever but
uh i'll just i'll just rephrase it
we had uh jack pacobic on the show and
he's mentioned this a couple times that
we all believed that if we opened up to
china and we went there and said look at
all of our amazing capitalism look at
our amazing constitution
that they would say this is brilliant
and we want to adopt it
instead what happened was that many
politicians went over to china
and said wait a minute you built this
building
how fast was it done you mean you just
snapped your fingers and you just
removed the residence and then got to
build your building you mean you built
this road in how many
days wow in america we have to deal with
all this bureaucracy
how do we do it and so the idea i
suppose is that what ended up happening
was americans realized
that it's faster and easier if you just
trample over people's rights and the
chinese communist party certainly
figured it out
now they started importing that here
why why bother with going to a court
to because you've got to deal with one
person's rights
it's like that movie up you ever see
that movie up where the old man has the
home
and the city is built around it but he
won't sell it and they want to take it
from him but he refuses
so what starts is this little house on a
hill
and then after you know 30 years or so
there's skyscrapers everywhere
they want to build the building but his
house is still there and they can't just
take it from him
well that movie wouldn't happen in china
would be banned
but if you made the movie up in china it
would be three minutes long where the
guy says you can't have my house and
they say you never owned the house in
the first place and then they just
steamroll it and then build a building
well during the operation process of
china so-called modernization building
you know skyscrapers high-rise housing
they actually mislocated lots of people
and you talk about admin domains bad in
america
talk about china you know
they i have a friend in new york city
now she's a political refugee
she had a 10 years 15 years factory
producing product services
during the economical boom and she got
rich because of that
all of a sudden the local government
said
we need your land to build
high-res housing because land belongs to
the state
remember all the lands all the natural
resources belong to the state in china
if you build something it's only the
structure on top of the land
is yours but even for that they want to
flat it and she went to court did not
want to
abolish her factory then court even said
it is her factory you cannot do this
it doesn't matter one party rule they
control courts
they control everything so the local
government like mafia
they bulldoze her factory and
she had to flee to come to this country
in order to try to
get her story told she even tried to
handle her paper to the
and she when she was visiting here so
when people talk about oh it's so
efficient
for the chinese government to build this
build that
they're also a very interesting invasion
to put one million people
in concentration camps in xinjiang today
and
harvesting people's organs and arresting
these pure human rights lawyers and the
citizen journalists who don't have a
license to practice to report
so do we want to become like them
democracy
constitutional republic you have a
process
everybody is entitled to fair trial fair
process
of voting to decide what to do you
cannot just
wipe out like during last year your
constitution right don't even matter
because we have a pandemic maybe chinese
leaked pandemic virus
with purpose of wake our economy and
cancel
all western countries citizens rights so
we'll be taken over
by communists you know what i've been
saying is
to the people who've read the books like
1984
did you think that the totalitarian
regime
wouldn't have an excuse did people
believe when they read 1984 that
the party that seized control one day
just got up and said we are taking
control and everyone said okay i guess
no it's always an excuse it's like v for
vendetta
you have you seen v for vendetta you
should definitely see that movie it's
great movie
yeah yeah it's a great it's well it's
it's it's a graphic novel series
um but the movie is fantastic and it
it's
a story about a totalitarian regime it's
in the uk
and for them it was it was a virus there
was i think it was called the saint
mary's virus in the film that
people got scared pharmaceutical company
then started coming out with the cure
that made tons of people rich the party
members all coincidentally got
really wealthy and it was their excuse
for seizing control
people were scared and so they gave up
that control but there's always
some excuse i love animals have you read
animal farm oh yeah
it's also george orwell and it's
basically i read it after i read 1984
but it's like
a version of what could lead up to 1984.
yeah you see the farm and the workers
take over because the farmer's not doing
a good enough job
they throw them out then the smartest of
the workers seem to take control of the
party
and the pigs it's a short book and the
famous saying that there are some
animals always more equal than
others that's right i know that like
today our tyrants governors
mayors and all the public health and
bureaucrats politicians
we get to told stay home no travel don't
say goodbye to your loved ones and shut
your business for public
goods that's what they told us in china
it's always excuse
to take away your rights and liberty
it's for public
good it's for public health it's for
society's stability
and you're not human beings you stay
home you must do this you must do that
do they have this authority to tell
another human being
those people are not gods they're not
angels they're not even
actually decent politicians they're
corrupted tyrants
and they tell me how to live my life
here that's like a hell no
hell no we need to march like the
european people did last weekend like
the great people did last weekend way
people who love freedom who have human
dignity need to
you light in the world there are so many
tyrants all want to become
the rulers their masters to control us
to have so much power is there nice like
a lot of rain i'm going to wear this one
ring
i have unlimited power i watch those
movies
it's like wow absolute power corrupts
absolutely and what is wrong with
americans today who believe authority
if it's a cells you fear you're gonna
just
lie down live on your knees and stay
home
i shot your business government give me
some unemployment checks
give me some stimulus and now inflation
is coming
it's like largest increase on your taxes
when inflation is so big
it hurts a working class it hurts the
poor but they don't understand
economics ah how come our kids don't
even study a book
called economics 101 that tells you
they don't want you to become smart you
want to dump down you that's easy to
sell your fear because you're afraid
if you're free you'll stay home you're
familiar with uh alexandria
ocasio-cortez
of course i can't debate her but she
totally grown me because i'm nobody
she has an economics degree and recently
on twitter
failed to define capitalism she had
started a business she was selling
merchandise she was criticized for
engaging in capitalism and being a
socialist and then she said that that's
not capitalism
capitalism is when wealthy people
exploit the working class
and just some very ideological and
biased view of what capitalism actually
means capitalism actually is a really
simple definition
the private uh private markets private
enterprise
the private exchange of goods and the
private trade and socialism is the
public
control of of the means of production so
a capitalist system there
there and there and there's uh um in
betweens you can be you have a mixed
economy we have a bit of a mixed economy
yeah we don't have total action imperial
capitalism at all
that's why people cannot understand when
they support bernie sanders
and demonize capitalism they think what
we have
is corporatism is capitalism so they
feel like
injustice of course there's lots of
income
gaps and there's a super rich in super
pool you know you have that in all this
society
but what is our alternative you want 100
million people die
and you want to one percent ruling class
over you so
what is alternative which is that's why
we need to have a conversations
how we're going to improve our lives
through more
like a fair competition that means we
actually free market real free market
capitalism everybody is equal
instead of we're talking about oh only
they billionaires
they can shut you down they can lock you
up
and they can sell you these things you
must buy because no more competition
left
because they want to make more money
that's not real capitalism this
embed with government to have a monopoly
that's totally wrong that's not fair to
regular common man
there's never going to be the equality
in
in terms of class the way these these
class theorists believe
that you could implement comp communism
and then all of a sudden people are even
uneven footing
because some people are still going to
be taller some people are still going to
be shorter
some people are still going to be faster
or stronger or weaker
or slower and some people are going to
be smarter
and the smart people will figure out how
to navigate these systems and
succeed and the people who aren't as
smart will probably struggle in that
regard
and there's nothing you can do to change
it i i these
these people don't understand they think
everyone must be equally as smart as
each other they think everybody's the
same height everybody's the same speed
if if we're in in the middle of the
woods and a grizzly bear or
about a black bear that's charging at us
well the taller faster person's not
going to get eaten
the world doesn't we can complain that
it's wrong that it sucks
that the world is this way right they
don't want to accept that
right team that's why equality is a
marxist term they want the equal outcome
that's what the com calmly is dead
they want everybody even look the same
if you wear glasses you get
killed if you are too tall you will cut
your legs half
because we want everybody look the same
is that insane
and the people buy into socialism
communism because he sounds
utopian sounds wonderful but it never
came mao promised land to the peasants
intellectuals to have free idea free
expectations
then he never give the land to peasants
he never gave her intellectuals
and even the journalists the freedom to
practice to speak up
lots of journalists in the country are
leaning left
they really don't understand history
either teachers too they were
indoctrinating colleges
training teachers all about left marxism
because it sounds wonderful they're
compassionate i
understand but the thing is when you
look at the system
when you when you look at actually what
happened when you went to that kind of
system
only one percent ruling all equally poor
people you don't get what you wanted you
decided for
and you were being slave because
everybody is relying on government
instead of yourself
responsibility families churches
communities the results just disastrous
it's a lot worse than what the bernie
sanders would like to believe
or they'll say i would like to talk to
her if she wants to sit down with me i
invited her to sit down with me
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8 pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you